To spend your time efficiently, you need to break your goals down into small chunks.
Firstly, you ought to break down your life into the different roles you play as a worker or manager,...
...member of an organization, blogger, husband or wife, etc.
You then set long-term goals for each of these roles.
This will help balance your life.
Each week, you should be working in small parts towards your long-term aims.
Because you have unavoidable events every week, you should use a weekly planner.
Leave some space for the unexpected.
Schedule the most essential items for your goal list into the blank spaces in your day planner.
Before the end of each day, take some time with your weekly goal sheet...
...and include whatever is possible in the next day's plan.
Also, include things like phone calls and emails.
In this way, the daily plans will match up with your weekly goals.
By setting weekly goals, organizing daily tasks and working hard, you will get there.